ну друзі що дочекалися тепер нижче мої
місцеве самоврядування парламент знищено
уряд де я так розумію в країні не існує
час знищити і місцеве самоврядування нам
говорять потрібні гроші так потрібні
потрібні гроші на перемогу так потрібні
то нарешті припиніть витрачати їх на
барабани і серіали Нарешті припиніть їх
витрачати на свої безглузді ідеї на
будівництво доріг нам розповідають що
бруківка не вбила жодного ворога а чого
ви три роки в асфальт вкладали гроші
Коли ми казали доробіть танки робіть
нептуни працюйте на армію на країну а
тепер вам все мало не можете не жратися
і треба забрати гроші у місцевих
бюджетів заберіть це ж геть все місцеве
самоврядування децентралізація одна з
найуспішніших реформ в Україні Годі вже
щось нищити будуйте